pese a que yo te impacto en el caribe
nicaragüense fue aquí en el sur
específicamente departamentos como
managua carazo y rivas en donde tuvo
grandes afectaciones debido al acumulado
de agua estoy con concepción martínez
ella perdió su vivienda prácticamente
debido a la crecida de este río junto
donde usted habita como pues fue algo
que nunca habías había visto
dicen que antes de nada
la vida de antes nadie la gente vieja
poemas adulta dice que nunca había
sucedido esto hasta hoy hasta ustedes
sabían del huracán pero nadie les avisó
que debían evacuar si sabíamos porque
hemos visto en las noticias pero no otra
vez se dicen hacen alarmas pero no
no sucede entonces a sí mismo lo
confiamos esta vez podría mostrarnos los
daños en sus viviendas y cuénteme cómo
fue y a qué hora ustedes se percataron
cómo lograron salir ilesos de esto
eso fue a las 10 de la noche
o cuando eran amantes estaba todo título
está inundado
yo solo logré sacar a mis hijos mis tres
tipos
y ya tenía que cuál cuál es el daño
si lo ha cuantificado hasta ahora bueno
aquí es a mí se me llevó todas las cosas
de la cocina todos los ministrantes
la ropa zapatos la comida todo se me fue
esto fue hace más de 24 horas cómo están
donde están viviendo están en albergues
como esto estamos en casa de mi mamá ahí
estamos y vamos sobreviviendo el
gobierno alguna autoridad ha venido a
brindarles ayuda no
gracias y como concepción hay muchas
familias que no han podido acceder a la
ayuda humanitaria debido a que los
caminos los ríos se han crecido y los
han inhabilitado